good morning hank it's wednesday special
surprise bonus video that i might delete
later so for me one of the great
pleasures of being alive is being a fan
of stuff especially being a fan of stuff
made by people you care about loving the
loves of your loves is for me at least
just a wonderful source of joy and
connection and i offer all of that as
preface before saying that over the last
year sarah has been making collages and
i love them so much like i adore live
play love ugh with every fiber of my
beating heart or this sideways hat and
car telling us to be the women in our
life so what sarah does is comb through
old magazines many of them ones that
were marketed to women in the 1960s and
1970s and then take images and words
from them to form these wonderful
collage poems ask anyone now be anyone
or any room is the room or here's a
woman spinning through the air do this
it works like i don't want to get too
deep here but just the phrase it works
is so fascinating when re-contextualized
like this right like it works can either
refer to something that is effective or
effortful and who among us has not felt
vaguely twisty of late i mean acrobatics
both physical and otherwise are
alternately wondrous and terrifying and
at times both which
feels like now to me all of sarah's
collage poems are like this the more you
look the more interesting they get and
that is my favorite experience with art
or to put it in collage poem form the
important thing is now you can see
another thing i love about these collage
poems they use old imagery but they are
utterly contemporary like take this one
where an old nikon camera lens contains
within it an even older image of the bar
made in a famous mene painting sarah
made a fascinating art assignment video
about this painting and what makes it so
art historically significant but by
placing this barmaid in a new context we
see a very contemporary image right the
reflection of a human face in a camera
lens which by the way is what i'm
looking at right now it's also what we
do every time we take a selfie and every
time we hold our phone up to our faces
so that facial recognition technology
can save us the trouble with having to
type in a password and so on truly the
picture of the week sarah's collages
remind me a little bit of sister karita
kent's alphabet series where she created
collages around each letter of the latin
alphabet like one of my favorites is the
letter e where she quotes camus should
like to be able to love my country and
still love justice and like kent's work
i think sarah's collages are both
beautiful to look at and ethically
challenging and also wonderfully
interesting to ponder like in this one
images and smells of the so-called
natural intersect with the so-called
artificial and that which cannot be
bought intersects with that which can be
bought and now you can own positive
vibrations but they never take
themselves too seriously and they're
often very funny like magical thinking
there's nothing finer or confidence in
your tiger or one of my all-time
favorites i want you to know the vcr
broke down there is only one
i give up many of these were created as
project for awesome perks but sarah has
just released some as a collection of
note cards through dftba with all the
proceeds going to charity and they are
lovely and my favorite cards to write
thank you notes on and if you order them
before december 3rd in the us they will
arrive before christmas lincoln the
doobly-doo or you can just look at them
on instagram there are so many more on
instagram i just love them so much not
least because they remind me that magic
can be small
magic can be small that is so beautiful
and so true
hank i'll see you on friday